bienvenue dans ce cours sur la compréhension de l'information et du calcul quantiques, je m'appelle John Wattrus et je suis le
directeur technique de l'éducation chez IBM Quantum. Ceci est la 11ème leçon de la série et c'est la troisième leçon de la
troisième unité qui porte sur la formulation générale de l'information quantique. Cette leçon traite des mesures, qui représentent une
interface entre l'information quantique et classique. Quand une mesure est effectuée sur un système alors qu'il se trouve dans un
état quantique, de l'information classique est extraite, révélant quelque chose sur cet état quantique, et changeant ou
détruisant généralement cet état dans le processus. Dans une formulation simplifiée de l'information quantique, qui a été discutée
dans la première unité de la série, on restreint généralement notre attention aux mesures projectives, y compris le
type le plus simple de mesure : les mesures en base standard. Il est cependant possible de généraliser la notion de mesure
et ça s'avère être quelque chose d'assez utile. Dans cette leçon, on va parler des mesures dans toute leur généralité,
y compris comment elles sont décrites en termes mathématiques et comment elles s'inscrivent dans la formulation générale du calcul
quantique. Vers la fin de la leçon, on va aussi examiner quelques notions fondamentales liées aux mesures, notamment la discrimination d'états quantiques
et la tomographie d'états quantiques. Alors, commençons. Voici un aperçu de la
leçon. Comme on le fait souvent, on va commencer par les bases, y compris deux façons différentes mais équivalentes de
décrire les mesures en termes mathématiques. En particulier, on peut décrire les mesures par des collections de matrices
et on peut aussi les décrire comme des canaux, ce à quoi j'ai fait allusion dans la leçon précédente. On va aussi discuter des mesures partielles,
c'est-à-dire des mesures effectuées sur une seule partie d'un système composé
plus grand. Ensuite, on passera au théorème de Neymark, qui est un fait fondamental concernant les mesures et qui dit essentiellement
que les mesures générales peuvent toujours être mises en œuvre d'une manière simple qui rappelle les représentations de Stein spring
des canaux. En bref, les mesures générales peuvent toujours être mises en œuvre en introduisant d'abord un
système d'espace de travail initialisé, puis en effectuant une opération unitaire, et enfin en effectuant une mesure en base standard
sur le système d'espace de travail. Ça s'avère être assez facile à prouver et on verra comment ça se passe, et
on verra aussi comment ça se connecte aux mesures dites non destructives, que je vais décrire. Enfin, dans la dernière partie de la
leçon, on va discuter de la discrimination d'états quantiques et de la tomographie d'états quantiques. On va commencer par les descriptions
mathématiques des mesures. Les mesures nous fournissent une interface entre l'information quantique et
classique. Quand une mesure est effectuée sur un système alors qu'il se trouve dans un certain état quantique, de l'information classique
sur cet état quantique est extraite. De plus, l'état quantique est généralement changé ou possiblement
complètement détruit. Initialement, on va concentrer notre attention sur les mesures dites destructives, où
un état quantique entre et seule de l'information classique en sort. Donc il n'y a pas de spécification de
l'état quantique post-mesure du système qui a été mesuré. Intuitivement, on peut imaginer qu'une mesure destructive
détruit le système qui a été mesuré, donc son état après la mesure n'est pas
spécifié. Ça ne signifie pas littéralement que les dispositifs physiques sont nécessairement détruits, c'est juste une description
mathématique, et c'est une description très utile parce qu'elle aide à garder les choses simples et à se concentrer sur les aspects
mathématiques essentiels des mesures. Il y a en particulier deux façons équivalentes de décrire les mesures destructives,
que j'ai mentionnées lors de l'aperçu de la leçon. Une façon de décrire une mesure destructive
est par une collection de matrices, où en particulier on a une matrice pour chaque résultat de mesure possible.
Une deuxième façon de décrire une mesure destructive est par un canal, où
l'entrée est l'état du système en cours de mesure et la sortie est toujours une matrice densité diagonale qu'on peut
interpréter comme une description d'une distribution de probabilité sur les résultats classiques possibles de la mesure.
Les deux descriptions sont équivalentes et c'est assez utile car ça nous permet de choisir la description la plus commode dans une
situation donnée. On va aussi parler des mesures non destructives, où en plus d'un résultat classique de mesure,
l'état quantique post-mesure du système qui a été mesuré est aussi
spécifié. Les mesures non destructives sont importantes et elles surviennent fréquemment, mais il y a un sens dans lequel elles sont
en quelque sorte moins fondamentales que les mesures destructives en termes mathématiques. En particulier, il s'avère que
les mesures non destructives peuvent toujours être décrites comme des compositions de canaux et de mesures destructives, et
on verra comment ça fonctionne un peu plus tard dans la leçon. Voyons maintenant comment les mesures, c'est-à-dire les mesures destructives,
peuvent être décrites comme des collections de matrices. Tout au long de cette discussion, on va supposer que X est un système qui est
en cours de mesure, et juste pour des raisons de simplicité, on va faire quelques hypothèses. D'abord, on va supposer que
l'ensemble d'états classiques de X est constitué des entiers de 0 à n moins un pour un certain entier positif n, et les résultats possibles
de la mesure sont les entiers de 0 à M moins un, encore une fois pour un certain entier positif M. Il n'y a pas besoin
d'avoir une relation entre les nombres n et M, ils sont tous les deux des entiers positifs arbitraires. Et bien sûr, on pourrait remplacer
ces ensembles par des ensembles d'états classiques arbitraires si on voulait faire ça. Rappelons d'abord comment fonctionnent les mesures projectives,
dont on a parlé pour la première fois dans la troisième leçon de la série. Étant donné qu'on suppose que
les résultats de mesure sont les entiers de 0 à n moins un, on décrit une mesure projective par une collection
de projections Pi 0 à Pi M moins un qui somment à la matrice identité, et ces matrices ont toutes des lignes et des
colonnes correspondant aux états classiques de X, autrement dit ce sont toutes des matrices n par n.
Si x est dans un état quantique décrit par un vecteur d'état quantique s, alors chaque résultat de mesure possible
a apparaît avec une probabilité égale à la norme euclidienne au carré de Pi a multiplié
par le vecteur s. La norme euclidienne au carré de n'importe quel vecteur est égale au produit scalaire de ce
vecteur avec lui-même, donc on obtient l'expression montrée à l'écran, et on peut simplifier ça juste un
peu en utilisant le fait que Pi a est une projection, donc le multiplier par lui-même ne fait
rien. Et enfin, on peut réécrire l'expression obtenue d'une façon légèrement différente en utilisant la propriété cyclique
WEBVTT
de la trace, comme indiqué à l'écran. Et si ce n'est pas clair pourquoi on veut écrire l'expression comme ça,
la réponse courte est qu'on aimerait comprendre comment les mesures projectives fonctionnent pour les matrices
densités. Et en particulier, par linéarité, si l'état de X est décrit par une matrice densité row plutôt
que par un vecteur d'état quantique s, alors la probabilité que le résultat a apparaisse est donnée par la trace de la projection
Pi a fois la matrice densité row. C'est nécessairement le cas parce que, comme on l'a vu,
on peut toujours penser à une matrice densité comme étant une moyenne pondérée d'états purs, et si on fait la moyenne des
probabilités correspondantes, on obtient cette expression parce que la trace est une fonction linéaire. Donc c'est l'expression qu'on
cherche, et on peut clarifier les choses juste un peu pour se concentrer sur les matrices
densités. Le point principal de faire ça, au fait, c'est d'établir un point de référence par rapport à ce qu'on a déjà appris
et de voir que cette description des mesures projectives est en fait un cas particulier d'une description plus générale des mesures qu'on
va voir maintenant. Donc ce que je vais faire maintenant c'est remplacer cette description du fonctionnement des mesures projectives pour les matrices densités
par la description pour les mesures générales, pour qu'on puisse comprendre la relation. Et voilà :
une mesure générale, pas nécessairement une mesure projective, est décrite par une collection de matrices semi-définies positives
p 0 à PM moins un qui somment à l'identité. Et si cette mesure est effectuée sur X alors qu'il se trouve
dans un état décrit par une matrice densité row, alors chaque résultat a apparaît avec une probabilité égale à la trace de PA *
row. En bref, la seule chose qui a changé c'est qu'on a assoupli la condition sur ces matrices. En particulier, les matrices
n'ont pas besoin d'être des matrices de projection, elles ont juste besoin d'être semi-définies positives, et en conséquence j'ai remplacé la lettre Pi par la lettre p
parce que Pi est un nom conventionnel pour une projection, alors que j'aime utiliser la lettre P pour les matrices semi-définies
positives. C'est une généralisation de la description qu'on avait pour les mesures projectives, au fait, parce que les matrices de projection sont toujours
semi-définies positives, et en fait elles peuvent alternativement être définies comme des matrices semi-définies positives dont les valeurs propres
ne peuvent être que zéro et un. On peut observer que cette définition
est cohérente en ce sens qu'on obtient toujours un vecteur de probabilité pour les probabilités des résultats de la façon suivante :
d'abord, ces nombres que j'ai qualifiés de probabilités de résultats sont toujours des nombres réels non négatifs, parce que
PA et row sont tous les deux semi-définis positifs et la trace du produit de deux matrices semi-définies positives
est toujours un nombre réel non négatif, et je te laisse réfléchir à la raison de
ça. Et deuxièmement, les nombres doivent sommer à un parce que la trace est linéaire,
les matrices p 0 à PN moins 1 sont requises pour sommer à l'identité, et les matrices densités ont une trace égale à
un. Donc peu importe de quelle matrice densité row on a commencé, les probabilités des résultats formeront toujours un
vecteur de probabilité. Voyons maintenant quelques exemples. J'ai déjà mentionné que
les mesures projectives sont un cas particulier des mesures générales parce que les projections sont toujours semi-définies positives,
mais c'est bien de commencer simplement, alors commençons par une mesure en base standard d'un qubit. On peut représenter une mesure en base standard
d'un qubit par deux matrices p 0 et P1 définies comme indiqué à l'écran. p 0 est z bra zero et P1 est k1
bra one. Ce sont toutes les deux des matrices semi-définies positives, et ce sont bien des projections, et elles somment clairement à
l'identité, donc ensemble elles décrivent une mesure. Si on applique cette mesure à un qubit
dans un état décrit par une matrice densité row, alors la probabilité que le résultat zéro apparaisse est la trace de p 0 * row
et la probabilité pour le résultat un est la trace de P1 * row. Et par la propriété cyclique de la trace, on obtient
les deux entrées diagonales de row comme on s'y attend. Voici un autre exemple où cette
fois les matrices ne sont pas des projections. Elles sont cependant semi-définies positives, et il se trouve qu'elles sont des matrices
densités, mais ça n'est pas important. Ce qui est important c'est qu'elles somment à l'identité, donc ensemble elles décrivent une
mesure. On peut voir ce qui se passe quand cette mesure est effectuée sur un qubit dans l'état plus, par exemple juste pour
voir comment ça fonctionne pour un exemple d'état. Et un calcul des probabilités est montré à l'
écran. Remarque en particulier que bien que l'état plus soit un état pur et qu'on puisse représenter cet état par le vecteur d'état quantique ket Plus, on doit
brancher la représentation en matrice densité de cet état, c'est-à-dire C plus BR plus, dans les formules pour obtenir
les probabilités. Et permettez-moi aussi de remarquer que parce qu'on parle d'une mesure destructive, il n'y a aucune
spécification de l'état quantique post-mesure de ce qubit. Donc tout ce qu'on a c'est une spécification des probabilités des
résultats. Voici un dernier exemple pour l'instant, et c'est un exemple assez intéressant. Encore une fois, c'est une mesure d'un
seul qubit, et pour la décrire, on va commencer par définir quatre vecteurs d'états quantiques connus sous le nom d'états
tétraédraux. Et la raison pour laquelle ils sont appelés états tétraédraux, c'est parce qu'ils correspondent aux quatre sommets d'un
tétraèdre régulier inscrit dans la sphère de Bloch. Et pour être clair, quand on dit que c'est un tétraèdre régulier,
on entend un solide à quatre faces où chacune des faces est un triangle équilatéral. Donc il y a une symétrie parfaite ici : chaque
arête a la même longueur et c'est le même angle qui est formé entre deux arêtes
adjacentes quelconques. Et maintenant on peut définir une mesure intéressante avec quatre résultats possibles, comme indiqué à l'écran. En mots, on peut prendre nos
matrices comme étant les représentations en matrice densité de ces états divisées par deux. Maintenant, ce sont clairement des matrices
semi-définies positives parce que ce sont des matrices densités divisées par deux, et tu pourrais faire le calcul pour vérifier
qu'elles somment effectivement à l'identité. Mais une autre façon de le voir est de penser à la symétrie : si on fait la moyenne de ces quatre états
ensemble, on obtient l'état complètement mélangé qui est au centre de la sphère de Bloch. Mais parce qu'on divise
chacun par deux plutôt que par quatre, on obtient deux fois l'état complètement mélangé, ce qui est l'identité. Je ne vais pas en dire plus sur
cette mesure pour l'instant, sauf pour observer qu'il ne s'agit pas d'une mesure projective, mais que c'est un bel exemple et
on la verra réapparaître plus tard dans la leçon. Une autre façon de décrire les mesures générales est comme des canaux, comme on va
maintenant le discuter. L'idée ici est que les états probabilistes classiques peuvent être représentés par des matrices densités diagonales, et donc
parce que les résultats des mesures sont classiques, on peut penser aux mesures comme étant des canaux où la sortie est toujours une matrice densité diagonale
WEBVTT
qui décrit le résultat de la mesure. Alors examinons ça en un peu plus de détail. Si on pense
abstraitement à une mesure générale, on peut décrire cette mesure comme un canal fi. Le système d'entrée du canal est
le système X qui est mesuré, et le système de sortie est un système y dont les états classiques correspondent aux
résultats de la mesure, que l'on considère comme les entiers de 0 à n moins un pour un certain entier positif
M. Et parce que les résultats des mesures sont classiques, on exige que pour toute matrice densité d'entrée row pour le système
X, la sortie cinq row soit une matrice densité diagonale. Par exemple, si on pense à une
mesure en base standard d'un qubit et qu'on pense à cette mesure comme étant décrite par un canal, on peut l'exprimer comme on l'a ici à l'écran.
Si la matrice densité d'entrée est row, alors on obtiendra le résultat zéro avec une probabilité égale à bra 0o row kat Zer
et on obtiendra le résultat un avec la probabilité bra one row Kat one. Et donc si on exprime ces résultats classiques
de mesure comme des matrices densités, on obtiendra cette expression pour le canal correspondant. Et il s'avère
que ce n'est rien d'autre que le canal de déphasage complet. Et c'est cohérent avec l'idée que le canal de déphasage complet
représente une forme extrême de décohérence, ce qui peut vouloir dire différentes choses, mais quand j'utilise ce terme je parle
de la tendance des états quantiques à devenir classiques parce que l'environnement autour du système dont on parle
observe d'une certaine façon, autrement dit il mesure.
Donc les résultats des mesures peuvent être décrits comme des canaux comme je viens de le décrire, mais ce n'est pas juste une possibilité, c'est une
caractérisation des mesures générales. Et ce que je veux dire par là, c'est ce qui suit. Bien sûr, il y a des canaux
qui ne représentent pas des mesures parce que la sortie pourrait ne pas être toujours une matrice densité diagonale. Mais si
la sortie d'un canal est toujours une matrice densité diagonale quel que soit l'état d'entrée row qu'on choisit, alors il est nécessairement possible de
exprimer ce canal sous la forme montrée à l'écran pour un certain choix d'une mesure, c'est-à-dire une collection de matrices
semi-définies positives qui somment à l'identité. Et c'est bien pour plusieurs raisons, y compris le fait que ça
nous dit essentiellement que notre définition des mesures comme collections de matrices ne manque
rien. Une autre façon de le dire est que cette façon de penser aux mesures comme des canaux est opérationnelle
ou peut-être axiomatique, dans le sens où ça capture ce qu'une mesure devrait être, c'est-à-dire un processus physique qui
transforme l'information quantique en information classique. Et il s'avère que c'est complètement équivalent à notre première
description des mesures, qui est purement algébrique. Je ne vais pas montrer la preuve de l'équivalence dans cette vidéo, mais elle
n'est pas difficile, et si tu es intéressé tu peux trouver la preuve dans le matériel écrit de la leçon qui est lié dans la description
de la vidéo. On a discuté de ce qui se passe quand une mesure générale est effectuée sur un système dans un état donné,
du moins pour le cas des mesures destructives. Ensuite, on va parler des mesures partielles, c'est-à-dire qu'une seule
partie d'un système composé est mesurée. Pour être précis, supposons qu'on ait une paire de systèmes XZ qui
ensemble sont dans un état décrit par une matrice densité row, et une mesure décrite par une collection de matrices semi-définies positives qui somment à
l'identité est effectuée sur le système X seul. Naturellement, ça résulte en un
résultat de mesure, et parce qu'on parle de mesures destructives, on peut imaginer que le processus de mesure détruit le système
X. Mais on a encore le système Z dont il faut se préoccuper, et on doit comprendre comment la mesure de X affecte
l'état de Z. D'abord, parlons des probabilités
des résultats. Parce qu'on parle d'une mesure du seul système X, les probabilités pour que différents
résultats apparaissent ne peuvent dépendre que de l'état de X en isolation, c'est-à-dire qu'elles ne peuvent dépendre que de
l'état réduit de X. En particulier, la probabilité qu'un résultat donné a apparaisse est donnée par
la même formule qu'avant, qui est la trace de PA fois l'état réduit de X que l'on note row
subx. L'état row subx est obtenu à partir de row en traçant Z, donc on peut faire cette
substitution. Et bien que ce ne soit pas immédiatement évident, la question qu'on obtient peut alternativement être écrite comme indiqué
à l'écran. C'est la trace de PA tensorisé avec la matrice identité sur le système Z *
row. C'est une égalité qui vaut la peine de prendre un peu de temps pour vérifier. C'est intuitif : on ne fait
rien du tout à Z, donc il est logique que l'identité sur Z apparaisse comme ça. Mais ça peut aussi être vérifié
algébriquement, et je te laisse ça avec la suggestion de d'abord considérer le cas où row est un produit tensoriel de deux matrices, puis
d'utiliser la linéarité pour conclure que ça doit fonctionner pour tout row. Et je vais aussi dire que ça ne dépend pas du fait que PA
est semi-défini positif ou que row est une matrice densité. C'est une égalité qui fonctionnerait pour tout choix de
matrices à la place de PA et row, du moment qu'elles ont les bonnes dimensions pour que l'expression ait
un sens. Voyons maintenant comment l'état de Z est affecté par la mesure. Et l'approche naturelle à mon
avis est de penser à la mesure comme un canal. Voici le canal qu'on associe à notre mesure, et on
pense à ça comme un canal du système X vers un nouveau système y dont les états classiques correspondent aux résultats de la mesure. Donc dans cette formule,
Sigma représente un état du seul système X. Si on applique ce canal au
système X pendant que la paire XZ est dans l'état row, on obtiendra la matrice densité qu'on a juste ici. Encore une fois,
prends autant de temps que nécessaire pour vérifier ça, et encore une fois je te suggère de d'abord considérer le cas où row est un produit
tensoriel de deux matrices, puis d'utiliser la linéarité. On a vu ce type d'état
où le premier système est classique et le second système est quantique comme exemple dans la leçon sur les matrices
densités. Chaque a se produit avec une certaine probabilité qui est la trace du second facteur tensoriel. Donc tu peux penser
à ces seconds facteurs tensoriels comme étant des matrices densités multipliées par des probabilités. Donc pour obtenir l'état de
Z conditionné à l'obtention d'un résultat de mesure particulier a, on divise simplement par la probabilité, autrement dit on
normalise le second facteur tensoriel en le divisant par sa propre trace. Donc en résumé, si on effectue une
mesure sur X pendant que la paire XZ est dans l'état row, voici ce qui se passe : d'abord, chaque résultat a apparaît
avec une probabilité égale à la trace de PA tensorisé avec l'identité fois row. Et deuxièmement, conditionné à l'obtention
WEBVTT
d'un résultat de mesure particulier a, l'état de Z est donné par l'expression montrée à l'écran, qui est ce qu'on obtient
en normalisant la matrice qu'on vient de voir il y a un moment. Et c'est la même chose que diviser la matrice par la probabilité
pour a d'apparaître. Je dois mentionner que ça n'a de sens que si la probabilité est non nulle, sinon on divise
par zéro. Mais ce n'est pas grave parce qu'on n'a pas besoin de se préoccuper de choses qui ne se produisent pas. Dans cette partie de
la leçon, on va discuter d'un théorème simple mais fondamental sur les mesures connu sous le nom de théorème de Neymar.
En bref, ce qu'il dit c'est que toute mesure peut être mise en œuvre comme la figure à l'écran
le suggère. Pour formuler ça en mots, une mesure générale donnée sur un système X peut être mise en œuvre de la façon suivante :
on introduit d'abord un système d'espace de travail initialisé y dont les états classiques sont les résultats possibles de la mesure, qu'on suppose numérotés
de 0 à n moins un. Ensuite, une opération unitaire U est effectuée sur la paire
YX, puis une mesure en base standard est effectuée sur y. Donc tout est essentiellement défini ici
sauf pour le choix de U. Et ce que dit le théorème c'est qu'il est en fait possible de choisir cette opération unitaire
U de telle sorte que les probabilités pour les différents résultats coïncident toujours avec la mesure générale
donnée. Voyons maintenant comment le théorème de Neymar est prouvé, et ce n'est pas difficile. On doit juste faire un bon choix pour
l'opération unitaire U et vérifier que ça fonctionne. Mais d'abord, on a besoin d'un fait de base
de la théorie des matrices : pour toute matrice semi-définie positive P, il y a toujours une unique matrice semi-définie positive
Q telle que Q au carré est égal à P. En général, il pourrait y avoir plusieurs matrices dont le carré donne P, mais
il y en a toujours une seule qui est semi-définie positive. La notation qu'on utilise pour désigner cette matrice est la racine carrée de
P, et c'est aussi comme ça qu'on s'y réfère en mots. Si tu veux calculer la racine carrée de P pour une
matrice semi-définie positive P, au fait, tu peux le faire en calculant d'abord une décomposition spectrale de P, puis
en remplaçant chacune des valeurs propres par sa racine carrée et en laissant les vecteurs propres inchangés. Les valeurs propres sont toutes
non négatives, donc ça a du sens, et il est assez facile de voir que la matrice obtenue est bien semi-définie positive
et dont le carré donne P. Le fait qu'elle soit unique est une autre affaire ; ce n'est pas difficile de
le prouver en utilisant des faits de base sur les matrices, mais c'est un peu tangentiel à la leçon et on va juste prendre cette partie
comme acquise. Et maintenant qu'on a ce concept en main, il est assez facile de spécifier une
opération unitaire U qui fonctionne. Toute matrice unitaire qui correspond au modèle montré à l'écran
fonctionnera en fait. Les n premières colonnes, en supposant que X a n états classiques comme avant, sont obtenues en empilant les racines carrées des
matrices qui décrivent la mesure les unes sur les autres, et les colonnes restantes peuvent être ce qu'on
veut, peu importe, du moment que toute la matrice est unitaire.
Et au fait, si tu remarques une ressemblance avec la connexion entre les représentations de Krauss et de Stein spring des canaux, ce n'est pas une coïncidence.
En fait, ce qu'on a ici est essentiellement un cas particulier de ça, où nos matrices cross sont toutes
semi-définies positives. Donc il y a deux choses qu'on doit vérifier : la première c'est que ce choix de U fonctionne vraiment, et
la seconde c'est qu'il est possible de choisir les colonnes non spécifiées d'une façon qui rende U unitaire. Alors commençons par la première.
Voici l'état avec lequel on commence : le système du bas Y est initialisé à l'état zéro tandis que le système du haut
commence dans l'état row. Ensuite on effectue U, ce qui signifie qu'on conjugue par
U. On peut écrire tout ça en termes de matrices par blocs comme montré à l'écran. On a U à gauche, U dagger à
droite, et K zero bra zero tensorisé avec row au milieu, ce qui prend la forme qu'on a ici, avec row dans
le coin supérieur gauche et des zéros partout ailleurs. Et si tu réfléchis à ce produit un instant, il est évident que les
entrées non spécifiées de U n'ont aucune importance car elles sont toujours multipliées par des entrées nulles de cette
matrice au milieu. Et si on fait le calcul, on obtient cette
matrice montrée juste ici, décrite comme une matrice par blocs. Ou alternativement, on peut l'exprimer en utilisant la notation directe
comme ça. C'est en fait la forme la plus commode pour nous, alors concentrons-nous sur cette
expression. Et par commodité, donnons à cette matrice qui est une matrice densité le nom
Sigma. La dernière étape est la mesure en base standard sur y, alors calculons l'état réduit de y.
C'est facile étant donné l'expression qu'on a : on trace simplement X, ce qui correspond au second facteur
tensoriel. Donc la probabilité pour un résultat a quelconque d'apparaître est l'entrée diagonale correspondant à a. On peut écrire
ça comme ça, et ça est égal à la trace de la racine carrée de PA * row * la racine carrée
de PA. Et par la propriété cyclique de la trace, on obtient la trace de PA * row,
ce qu'on espérait. Donc les probabilités pour les différents résultats d'apparaître sont correctes, elles coïncident toujours
avec la mesure originale avec laquelle on a commencé. La deuxième chose qu'on doit vérifier
c'est qu'il est possible de remplir les colonnes non spécifiées de U d'une façon qui le rend
unitaire. Ça découle du fait que les n premières colonnes, qui sont celles formées par les racines carrées des matrices qui décrivent la
mesure, sont orthonormales. Et ça peut être vérifié assez directement. Les détails pertinents sont ici
à l'écran, alors mets la vidéo en pause et prends quelques instants pour y réfléchir si tu le souhaites. Mais comme je l'ai suggéré,
c'est en fait un cas particulier de quelque chose qu'on a rencontré dans la leçon précédente. Et c'est la
preuve. Jusqu'à présent dans la leçon, on s'est concentré sur les mesures destructives, c'est-à-dire qu'il n'y a pas de spécification de
l'état quantique post-mesure du système qui a été mesuré. Pour une mesure non destructive en revanche, il y a
non seulement un résultat classique de mesure, mais aussi un état quantique post-mesure du système qui a été mesuré. Et comme
on va le voir, il y a une connexion naturelle avec le théorème de Neymar. Il y a en fait différentes façons de formuler les mesures non destructives
en termes mathématiques, mais on va commencer par une formulation qui découle directement du théorème de Neymar.
Considère une mesure générale, c'est-à-dire une mesure destructive, décrite par une collection de matrices semi-définies positives
p 0 à PN moins un qui somment à l'identité. On peut alors transformer cette
WEBVTT
mesure en mesure non destructive simplement en considérant la mise en œuvre de cette mesure qu'on a discutée dans le contexte du théorème de Neymar.
On introduit un nouveau système y, on le fait interagir avec X par une opération unitaire U, et ensuite on effectue une mesure en base standard
sur y. Donc le système X est encore là et on peut considérer son
état. Et d'après l'analyse qu'on a faite, on peut déterminer que l'état post-mesure de X conditionné
à l'obtention d'un résultat de mesure particulier a est donné par une matrice densité qui ressemble à
ça. En mots, on conjugue par la racine carrée de la matrice de mesure correspondante, puis on
normalise. Une autre façon de formuler les mesures non destructives, qui est plus générale, est en termes de matrices
cross des canaux. Et c'est la définition des mesures qu'on trouve dans le manuel bien connu de Neil et
Trang par exemple. Supposons que m0 à m m moins 1 soient des matrices carrées qui satisfont
l'équation montrée à l'écran, ce qui veut dire qu'on peut penser à ces matrices comme étant des matrices cross qui décrivent un
canal. En fait, ces matrices décrivent un canal, mais elles décrivent aussi une mesure non destructive.
Et la façon dont ça fonctionne quand un système dans un état donné row est mesuré est : d'abord, les probabilités des résultats sont
données par l'équation montrée à l'écran. Chaque résultat apparaît avec une probabilité égale à la trace de ma *
row * ma dagger. Et conditionné à l'apparition du résultat a, l'état du système
mesuré ressemble à ça. Les mesures non destructives de ce type peuvent être mises en œuvre d'une façon
similaire à ce qu'on avait pour le théorème de Neymar, et je te laisse ça à réfléchir si tu
le souhaites. Il est possible de généraliser le concept de mesure non destructive encore plus loin que ça, par exemple
il y a un concept d'instrument dit quantique qui est parfois très utile, mais je ne vais pas couvrir ça dans cette
vidéo. Dans la dernière partie de la leçon, je vais brièvement discuter de deux tâches associées aux mesures : la discrimination d'états quantiques et la tomographie d'états quantiques.
Il y a beaucoup à dire sur ces deux concepts et on va vraiment juste effleurer la
surface. Alors commençons par clarifier à quoi ces termes font référence et comment ils diffèrent.
D'abord, la discrimination d'états quantiques. L'idée ici c'est qu'on a une collection connue d'états quantiques
d'un système, avec des probabilités associées à ces états. Donc pour être précis, supposons
que row 0 à row M moins 1 sont des matrices densités représentant des états quantiques possibles d'un système X, et p 0
à PN moins un sont des probabilités associées à ces états. Donc si on collecte les probabilités dans un seul
vecteur, on obtient un vecteur de probabilité. Une façon succincte de dire ça est qu'on a un ensemble d'états quantiques.
Et maintenant, une façon abstraite de penser à la discrimination d'états quantiques comme tâche ou comme problème
est la suivante : d'abord, un nombre entre Z et N moins un est choisi aléatoirement selon les probabilités. Le système X est ensuite
préparé dans l'état correspondant au nombre sélectionné aléatoirement, et le but est de déterminer par
des mesures de X quel nombre a été choisi. Donc on a un nombre fini d'
alternatives avec un a priori, et le but est de déterminer quelle alternative s'est réellement produite. Pour certains choix d'états et de
probabilités, ça peut être facile, et pour d'autres il peut ne pas être possible de faire ça sans avoir une certaine chance de faire une erreur.
Et il y a diverses questions spécifiques qu'on pourrait poser, par exemple quelle est la probabilité minimale de faire une erreur,
et à quoi ressemble une mesure qui atteint cette probabilité d'erreur minimale ? La tomographie d'états quantiques,
d'autre part, est différente. Ici on a un état quantique inconnu d'un système. Donc il n'y a
généralement pas d'a priori ni d'information sur les alternatives possibles. Cette fois cependant, ce n'est pas une seule copie de l'état qui est rendue
disponible, mais plutôt de nombreuses copies indépendantes, ce qui veut dire que pour un certain nombre peut-être grand
n, on a n systèmes identiques X1 à xn qui sont chacun préparés indépendamment dans l'état
row. Et cette fois, le but est de trouver une approximation de cet état quantique inconnu sous forme de matrice densité en mesurant
les systèmes. Donc en résumé, dans la discrimination d'états quantiques on a une seule copie de
l'état et on essaie de discriminer parmi un nombre fini d'alternatives connues. Et dans la tomographie d'états quantiques on a de nombreuses copies indépendantes
d'un état quantique inconnu, et le but est de trouver une description de cet état ou au moins une bonne approximation de
celui-ci. La discrimination d'états quantiques est intéressante parce qu'elle abstrait un type de situation qui survient fréquemment en
calcul et en cryptographie par exemple, où une alternative parmi un ensemble fini de possibilités a eu lieu et nous ou quelqu'un d'autre essaie
de déterminer laquelle en mesurant un système quantique. Le cas le plus simple non trivial est
celui où il n'y a que deux alternatives, c'est-à-dire que m est égal à deux, donc la tâche est de discriminer entre une paire
d'états. Ce cas s'avère être essentiellement un problème complètement résolu, en supposant que le but est de minimiser
la chance d'une discrimination incorrecte. Il y a un choix optimal pour une mesure et on l'appelle souvent
la mesure de Helstrom. C'est en fait une mesure projective, et elle peut être décrite comme
suit : d'abord, on considère la différence pondérée entre les deux alternatives, c'est-à-dire p 0 * row 0 moins P1 * row one.
Donc on multiplie la probabilité de tirer chacun de ces deux états par les états eux-mêmes, et on prend la
différence. C'est une matrice hermitienne parce qu'elle est égale à sa propre transposée conjuguée, donc elle a une décomposition
spectrale, et on sait en particulier que les valeurs propres sont toutes des nombres réels. Alors supposons qu'on ait une
décomposition spectrale écrite dans la forme montrée à l'écran. Ce qu'on fait ensuite c'est de rassembler les
valeurs propres en deux ensembles, où toutes les valeurs propres positives sont dans un ensemble et toutes les valeurs propres négatives sont dans
l'autre. Pour être précis, prenons S0 comme l'ensemble de tous les indices k pour lesquels la valeur propre correspondante Lambda K est
non négative, et prenons S1 comme les indices restants, qui sont ceux correspondant aux valeurs propres
négatives. Peu importe en fait dans quel ensemble se trouvent les indices correspondant à toutes les valeurs propres nulles, ici on fait
un choix arbitraire d'inclure les moins zéro mais ça ne ferait aucune différence si certains ou tous d'entre eux étaient inclus dans S1 plutôt. Tout ce qui compte vraiment c'est
qu'on sépare les valeurs propres positives et négatives. Et enfin, on définit deux projections Pi
0 et Pi 1 comme indiqué à l'écran. En mots, Pi 0 est la projection sur le
WEBVTT
sous-espace engendré par les vecteurs propres correspondant aux valeurs propres non négatives, et Pi 1 est la projection sur l'espace
engendré par les vecteurs propres correspondant aux valeurs propres négatives. Ce sont bien des projections, et
si on les additionne on obtient la matrice identité parce que les vecteurs propres S 0 à S N moins un forment une
base orthonormale. Si cette mesure est effectuée dans la situation actuelle, c'est-à-dire que
l'état mesuré est row 0 avec probabilité p 0 et row one avec probabilité P1, alors il s'avère que
la probabilité d'une identification correcte a une formule assez simple en termes des valeurs propres Lambda 0 à Lambda n moins
un. Je ne vais pas entrer dans les détails du calcul dans cette vidéo. Tu peux consulter le contenu écrit lié dans la description de la vidéo si tu es
intéressé, ou voir si tu peux te convaincre toi-même que cette formule est bien correcte. On peut aussi exprimer cette
probabilité en utilisant une norme matricielle communément appelée la norme de trace. La notation est similaire à la norme euclidienne pour les vecteurs,
sauf qu'on a un indice de un pour indiquer que c'est la norme de trace. La norme de trace est très importante et elle est
très souvent rencontrée en informatique quantique, mais je n'en dirai pas plus à ce sujet dans cette leçon. Une façon de
la définir pour les matrices hermitiennes est que c'est la somme des valeurs absolues des valeurs propres, donc tu peux penser
à cette deuxième égalité comme découlant directement de cette définition. La norme de trace peut aussi être
définie d'autres façons plus générales, et on rencontrera à nouveau la norme de trace dans la prochaine leçon. C'est en fait
le meilleur qu'on puisse faire : cette mesure est optimale en supposant que ton but est de maximiser la chance d'une
bonne estimation. Ce fait est parfois appelé le théorème de Helstrom-Holevo et parfois juste appelé le théorème
de Helstrom. Donc tu ne peux pas battre cette mesure en termes de probabilité de correction, et c'est bien parce que
il y a une recette simple pour la mesure elle-même et une formule exacte pour la probabilité de correction en termes de la norme de
trace. La norme de trace est souvent utilisée comme façon de mesurer la différence observable entre des matrices densités pour
précisément cette raison. Et quand les gens font référence à la distance de trace entre des états, ils font généralement référence à
un demi fois la norme de trace de la différence entre les deux matrices densités, ce qui correspond ici au cas où p 0 et P1 valent tous les deux 1/2, ce qui
est un cas naturel à considérer. La discrimination d'états quantiques pour deux états est résolu de façon optimale par
la mesure de Helstrom, pour laquelle on a une recette simple et une formule simple pour la probabilité de
correction. Alors que se passe-t-il quand on veut discriminer parmi trois états ou plus ? Dans ce cas, on n'a pas de
formule générale pour un choix optimal d'une mesure ni d'expression simple pour la probabilité maximale de
correction. Il est cependant possible de trouver une bonne approximation d'une mesure optimale avec l'aide d'un ordinateur,
et en particulier ça peut être fait en utilisant une technique d'optimisation vraiment fascinante et puissante connue sous le nom de programmation semi-définie. Mais ce n'est pas
quelque chose qu'on peut réaliser de façon pratique avec un crayon et une feuille de papier par exemple. D'autre part, si quelqu'un
te donne une description d'une mesure et prétend que cette mesure est optimale pour une tâche de discrimination d'états quantiques, alors il est
en fait très facile de soit vérifier soit de réfuter cette affirmation. Et ça pourrait être fait en utilisant les conditions dites de Holevo-Yuen
Kennedy-Lax. Je ne vais pas expliquer ce qu'elles sont dans cette vidéo, mais ce sont des conditions simples et c'est assez cool
que ce soit possible. Voici un exemple qui nous ramène aux états tétraédraux
qu'on a vus plus tôt dans la leçon. Supposons qu'on nous donne un de ces quatre états sélectionné au hasard avec
probabilité un quart pour chacun, et que notre but est de déterminer quel état on nous donne. Ce n'est peut-être pas surprenant, mais
le meilleur choix que tu puisses faire pour une mesure pour faire ça est la mesure tétraédrale. Tu ne peux pas toujours faire
quelque chose comme ça pour une collection arbitraire d'états purs, mais à cause des symétries en jeu ici, ça
fonctionne, et on obtient effectivement une mesure valide. Et grâce aux conditions de Holevo-Yuen Kennedy-Lax que j'ai mentionnées
il y a quelques instants, il s'avère être assez simple de prouver que c'est bien un choix optimal de
mesure. Plus précisément, ce qui se passe ici c'est que la mesure est toujours correcte avec une probabilité de 1/2, ce qui n'est
pas mal parce qu'il y a quatre alternatives, donc la probabilité d'une bonne estimation est deux fois meilleure que la devinette aléatoire. Et
c'est le meilleur qu'on puisse faire pour ces états. Maintenant je vais dire juste un peu plus sur la tomographie d'états quantiques,
où on a de nombreuses copies indépendantes d'un état quantique inconnu et où le but est de trouver une approximation de la matrice densité qui décrit
cet état. Il y a en fait plusieurs variantes différentes de ce problème qui dépendent de tes hypothèses et en
particulier du type de mesures que tu autorises. Par exemple, on pourrait exiger que chaque système soit mesuré individuellement et
que les résultats soient combinés d'une façon ou d'une autre pour arriver à une description de la matrice densité. Ou on pourrait permettre à tous les
systèmes d'être mesurés ensemble comme un seul système composé, ce qui est beaucoup mieux en théorie mais c'est aussi beaucoup plus
exigeant d'un point de vue technologique. En plus des choix qu'on fait pour les mesures, il y a
aussi une considération importante qui est de savoir comment reconstruire une description de la matrice densité à partir de quelles que soient les données qu'on
obtient des mesures. Je ne vais pas entrer dans les détails à ce sujet : mon point est simplement de suggérer
que la tomographie d'états quantiques est vraiment davantage un concept parapluie ayant de nombreuses variantes différentes, plutôt qu'une
procédure unique. Il y a eu beaucoup de recherche sur ce problème, y compris des résultats
récents assez remarquables qui relient le nombre de copies n à la précision de l'approximation qui peut être obtenue. Et ça continue d'être un
domaine de recherche intéressant et actif. Pour terminer la leçon, regardons la tomographie d'états quantiques
pour les qubits et comment on peut la faire. Supposons donc que row est une matrice densité représentant l'état d'un
seul qubit, et que X1 à xn sont des qubits qui ont tous été préparés indépendamment dans l'état row. Et pour
les besoins de cette discussion, supposons que n est grand. Ce qu'on peut faire c'est de diviser les
systèmes en trois piles à peu près égales. Et pour la première pile, on va effectuer une mesure par rapport à la base plus
moins. Pour chaque résultat correspondant à plus on va noter plus un, et pour chaque
résultat correspondant à moins on va noter moins un. Une façon plus succincte de décrire cette mesure
est que c'est une mesure Pauli X parce que les états plus et moins sont des vecteurs propres de la matrice Pauli X et les
valeurs propres correspondantes sont plus un et moins un. Et en fait c'est aussi une façon beaucoup plus commune de la décrire.
WEBVTT
En effet, la valeur attendue du score est égale à la trace de Sigma x * row. Maintenant, on n'apprend pas nécessairement quelle est
cette valeur attendue, mais si on fait la moyenne des scores qu'on obtient sur beaucoup beaucoup d'essais, on est assez susceptible d'obtenir une
bonne approximation de cette valeur attendue par la loi des grands nombres. Et il y a des bornes statistiques bien connues qu'on peut appliquer à
ça si on veut être plus quantitatif sur cette affirmation. On fait quelque chose de similaire avec Sigma y sur le second tiers des
systèmes. La seule chose qui change ici c'est qu'on utilise les états plus i et moins i qui sont des vecteurs propres de Sigma
Y. Et de même pour Sigma Z, pour lequel les vecteurs de base standard sont des vecteurs
propres. Et enfin, on peut utiliser la formule montrée à l'écran qui nous dit quels devraient être les coefficients
si row est écrit comme une combinaison linéaire de matrices de Pauli. Et en substituant nos approximations pour ces coefficients
et en les ajustant peut-être un peu pour s'assurer qu'on obtient une matrice semi-définie positive, on obtient une approximation de
row. Bien sûr, il y a des détails dans lesquels je ne suis pas entré, comme la précision de l'approximation et le degré de
confiance qu'on peut espérer avoir, mais j'espère que ça te donne une idée de base d'une façon dont la tomographie peut être effectuée sur un
qubit. Il est aussi possible de faire la tomographie d'un qubit en utilisant la mesure tétraédrale, et ça s'avère en fait
être assez simple et élégant, du moins en termes mathématiques. Ce qu'on peut faire c'est d'effectuer juste
cette unique mesure sur toutes les copies indépendantes de notre état quantique inconnu. Et en utilisant la
formule remarquable montrée juste ici, on peut arriver à une approximation de notre état en estimant la trace de PK *
row pour chaque K par la fraction de fois que le résultat de mesure correspondant apparaît. Encore une fois, ça ne fonctionne que parce que
les symétries parfaites qu'on a parmi ces quatre états. Et il y a en fait des problèmes non résolus vraiment fascinants qui sont liés aux généralisations
de cette approche à des systèmes plus grands. Et c'est un bon endroit pour terminer la leçon. Merci d'avoir regardé et
j'espère que tu me rejoindras pour la prochaine leçon qui porte sur les purifications et la fidélité. Au revoir pour l'instant.